-Lindsay Lohan and I are about
to face off in a water war.
We'll play the card game War,
but if you lose the hand,
you get a pint of water
in the face.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
The first person
to throw five glasses wins,
and gets to water-cannon
the loser.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yay!
[ Chuckles ]
-Lots of ways to get wet,
but only one way to win.
Lindsay, are you ready for this?
And we did not rig all of this.
-Never been more ready, Jimmy.
-I'm apologizing in advance.
-Okay, I just want to kind of
start 'cause I'm nervous.
-All right,
one, two, three, flip.
-Yes!
Merry Christmas to all!
-What are you talking about,
"Merry Christmas to all"?!
-Early!
-All right.
You get the first card.
Go.
Oh, my gosh.
You're having too much fun.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Didn't hold back
on that one at all.
That one actually --
-Sorry.
-Oh, get ready.
No, no, we're ready to play.
Let's go.
Let's do this.
All right.
[ Laughter ]
One, two, three, flip.
What?!
What's going on?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Maybe I should
move the deck around.
-Okay. I'll go gentle.
I'll go gentle.
-Yeah, you will?
No, it's all right.
-Here.
-That's all right.
Go for it if you're gonna do it.
You can go for it.
-No, I did it already.
-Okay. Oh, my --
You're being too nice
so I'm really gonna go for it.
All right.
-Oh, shoot.
-Do I trust this,
or should I switch hands?
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-One, two, three, flip.
Come on!
What's going on?!
It's a landslide!
This feels rigged!
All right, go for it,
go for it, go for it.
-Okay.
-Yep, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sorry.
I love you, I love you.
-Oh, my gosh.
This feels so rigged right now.
I am so mad.
All right, come on now!
Give me at least one win!
One, two, three!
-Oh, no!
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
-All right.
-Jesus, Mary, and Joseph.
[ Laughs ]
-I feel weird.
-No.
-You're in a beautiful dress.
-I deserve it, I deserve it.
-No.
I just -- I can't.
-Sorry to Versace.
[ Laughter ]
-Versace? I can't...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I can't.
-Aah!
Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I planned it to be really bad,
and you just did my arms?
-I realize it was very nice.
I feel -- I feel odd.
-I don't know if I'm
disappointed in that.
-Here we go. Ready?
One, two, three.
All right.
You're crushing right now.
Okay, go.
You did that one already!
Yeah, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Did you do it?
All right, do it twice.
Just -- God!
You're gonna milk out
the whole thing?
All right.
This is ridiculous.
I'm getting destroyed here.
Why did I agree to do this?
All right, here we go.
One, two, three, flip.
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wait.
Is that it?
-This is not normally
how this happens.
-We didn't get one war at all?
-I kind of want to try again
and see if we get a war.
-Yeah, let's go for it again.
This is good.
I like this.
Whoever loses this
gets the water cannon.
-Okay.
-So we go one...
-Oh, shoot.
-...two, three.
And now this is it.
-Okay.
-Thanks for coming on the show.
-[ Laughs ]
-Nice to see you.
-Have me back, please.
-Happy holidays.
[ Both laugh ]
Congrats on the movie, and...
Oh, yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
Just know I gave it to you.
-Are you sure?
-Okay.
All right, let's go.
-You're sure?
-Yes!
Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Here we go.
Here, you can get me.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Lindsay Lohan, everybody!
-I can't --
-Pfft!
Music from the --
Watch out for The Roots!
-Sorry, Quest!
-Watch out for The Roots!
Sorry, Quest.
Pfft!
1975 are coming up!
Come back!
Lindsay Lohan, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Tell 'em ♪